[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah today we're gonna make some ice
cream guys
we've got all the toppings set out gonna
be a quick and easy way to make homemade
ice cream at the comfort of your home
we're gonna make gelato smoothie bowls
ice cream sorbet
everything because we know summer is in
the weather is really really hot right
now in here in singapore
and it's just nice to cool down man yeah
but it's raining
what we've made is
vanilla ice cream the base we've made a
dairy free latte ice cream as well and a
watermelon pineapple with yuzu sobe so
i'm excited to try it out and we're
gonna we're gonna feed the office okay
these are hungry people ready for some
ice cream now we've tried the ninja dual
zone air fryer it's amazing i love it
and i gotta tell you i love ninja
products okay they're just
but if you're new to the channel hello
and welcome to geek culture we do
different kinds of content here from
tech toys to entertainment and now ice
cream the next video might be different
from this one so if you enjoyed this
video so far do give us a like and
subscribe it will help us a lot ice
cream is very easy to make but
you know
it's easy for me to cook stuff so i'm
gonna grab a guinea pig and this is
cheryl
this is a vanilla based ice cream
uh and then the one you have right here
it's a it's a little little take on
watermelon sorbet but i've added
pineapple and
yuzu infused honey because i know you
like yuzu yes and that's the best part
because if you don't know how to make
your ice cream
it comes with a recipe book this is like
a size of a regular isn't the egg and
dust chicken dust yes the thing is that
they didn't really say whether it's a
pint but it makes a serving of four
these tubs you take out the lid
it goes inside the outer bowl
right
snap on the top lid
and whisk away we'll show that very
shortly but what i love about ninja is
that they provide two extra
of this creamy tubs you gotta make your
ice cream base ahead of time
because it does take 24 hours to
completely freeze or what we call flat
freeze
ninja is really adamant about saying
exactly 24 hours
rather than like 16 hours or 12 hours
because you may think it's frozen it's
not i don't want to take the risk
because i don't want to spoil the
machine this does not only do ice cream
okay there's ice cream like ice cream
which is basically ice cream with less
sugar apparently or like a hybrid ice
cream and gelato sorbet milkshake
smoothie bowls and mix in by the mixing
function i'll keep that secret for later
are you referring for look i'm referring
to the cookbook
because if you can follow the recipe
you can basically
make ice cream okay let's measure
everything out here yes it's gonna like
combine and help you're gonna dissolve
better
yeah
and my secret ingredient to make things
a lot creamier
is to
add a little bit of coconut cream it
kind of gives it a more creamy flavor
so you got an apparatus this is called
the aggregation okay
like
you can see the oils here
how shiny it is yes you see that
of pistachio butter
i guess we are done yup and all you need
to do is to fill the ice cream tub at
max fuel line and freeze it for 24 hours
and while you wait you must await in
comfort with a secret lab chair
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
circuit lectures especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if pu leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colours
including this lovely frost blue the
tyson evo is even magnetized allowing
the hit pillow to stick on the headrest
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
secretlab.co in this case we've used all
the tubs we're going to transfer this
into another container or we just it you
can just leave it here
we can actually start with our one go
with vanilla first
okay it's action time ready yeah so
we're going from this this section here
into this 24 hours later you take out
the top
it's got a little bit of a nipple i
wonder why
on to the outer box
and you can see it sits it's like a
locking mechanism underneath
top auto ball so we're gonna put it up
like that
and then
click
and then you twist forward
oh that's satisfying and
let's go
no power
did you turn the unit on
no you didn't no you didn't turn the
thing on oh that's not
[Music]
[Applause]
a few moments later
[Music]
okay there we go see
okay
so you're probably wondering to yourself
you know why you make vanilla ice cream
well
what ninjas trying to like emphasize
here is that you make a base and then
you can mix in
toppings
so if you were to make cookies and cream
it's basically vanilla ice cream with
oreo cookie okay so it's more than just
tops you can actually incorporate
toppings and you can mix it back in with
the ninja creamy ice cream maker yes ah
thank you wanna put in your mix ins you
just gotta create a little hole yes you
have a center here like a well
okay like a well
and
and then just the mixing button
oh there we go
okay
oh so they did crush the beacons a
little bit
oh
no this is with beacons inside
you ain't trying everyone's to try guys
he's just watching
right
so this is what zeki had done earlier
basically instant coffee powder with
almond milk and coconut cream this is
this smells like the
coffee
don't forget a lot of sugar
oh okay whoa it is it has a
different texture
no no very thick right
i'm feeling the coffee man
is it because it's not cold enough
oh my oh this is nice
don't know jackie i think for the
downside of this right is that if you're
doing multiple flavors yeah multiple
batches you need to actually wash this
so you don't cross contaminate flavors i
mean that's also given now yeah but me
washing made easy
is so much better than very hard to wash
of course you can literally latch out
okay the blades
okay the last one that we have
watermelon uses sorbet just for the
sorbet version yup
i don't know whether because
my tongue is numb from all the ice
texture is right but the flavor
no taste watermelon is water you don't
eat this what it's a little bit of try
and error because i gotta admit when me
and amy you taste tested the liquid worm
it was perfectly fine yeah
but whole foods also
don't have much flavor right as in whole
typically
unless you really like anything what if
we just need to mix it up a little bit
more
what do you think of the ninja creamy
ice cream maker
i mean it's ice cream now so
how does that say but honestly give me a
gimmick
give me
give me and this is just great for
people who are interested in cooking
baking making desserts
this is a easy and surefire way to make
ice cream sorbet milkshake smoothie
bowls because if you think about the
price point at 299 singapore dollars
it's going to fit your home pretty well
for me i feel that
from the end to end process right and if
you didn't do the prep itself i can find
that
it might be trickier i mean this this
time around we actually shot this video
itself when we got three different
flavors yeah but i would think i imagine
if most people at home will be just
doing one favor so they're going to be
always repeatedly washing i think the
pros on this is really the wash up it's
very easy
yup
i don't think you really get that volume
though each time you're doing the
ingredients it might be even cheaper to
even buy your own your own pint of ice
cream okay you'll find a place on your
countertop to put this that's true yeah
you look at the size of this
not quite something that you actually
put let's say in our kitchen over there
yeah we have a nice spot over there we
have a nice spot but if anything else
comes in yeah
we have no space all right that wraps up
the video we hope you enjoyed it and if
you did do give us like and subscribe if
you have any questions about the ninja
ice cream maker do leave it down in the
comments section below and if you're
planning to get one for yourselves we
also have a link in our description page
so you can just check it out yeah okay
and that wraps it up this is a bit
different from our usual review videos
because it was shot on twitch so check
us out on that channel as well all right
with that's it i'm going to wrap it up
okay thanks zacky bye
[Music]
you